[Música]
a mucha gente no le gusta ver noticias
porque rara vez nos cuentan algo bueno y
a veces cuando cuentan algo bueno lo
cuentan mal yo escucho todos los días
decir a gente que tirada porque el
periodismo está en crisis me va presa de
noticias los periódicos no dicen muchas
cosas buenas entonces ahora imagínense
un cuadro como el de la foto niños de 89
años viendo uno de esos periódicos que
están llenos de fotos violentas de malas
noticias de mentiras que uno lo agarra
por la esquina y parece que chorrea
sangre eso es un cuadro muy triste
verdad ju cuando yo era pequeño me
gustaba muchísimo estar informado
siempre tuve acceso en mi pueblo en
guanacaste a tres periódicos uno era muy
comercial y con un par de suplementos
culturales de buena calidad otro muy
económico y con noticias del sector
empresarial y el tercero uno de esos
violentos con fotos feas de los que la
mamá no quisiera que uno vea pero mi
mamá siempre me dijo que convenía estar
informado y ver la diversidad
en la diversidad está la verdad bueno
creciendo en ese ambiente que tan bien
ponderaba la información y el periodismo
yo siempre me hice una pregunta porque
cuando escuchaba los noticieros en la
radio o en la televisión a veces no
entendía lo que decían los periodistas y
también me parecía que a ellos no le
importaban que los niños entendiéramos
lo que estaban diciendo como si no
existiéramos o como si no fuéramos
ciudadanos bueno eso es algo con lo que
todavía tenemos que lidiar no todos los
días vemos que alguien en los medios
digitales o en los tradicionales haga
noticias para niños yo nunca lo he visto
no sé si ustedes lo habrán visto
eso es algo que me preocupa mucho y de
esa preocupación que mantengo hasta el
día de hoy tengo también la otra que es
porque si a pesar de que la la
convención de derechos del niño en su
artículo 17 dice que todos los niños
tienen derecho a acceder a información
contextualizada de calidad y pertinente
para ellos para entenderla con sus
recursos intelectuales con su realidad
nadie les ha contado nunca el cuento
bueno veamos unos datos y unos datos
para entender cómo es la realidad en
américa latina' en costa rica según la
unicef viven alrededor de un millón y
medio de niños si vemos el dato en toda
américa latina son 190 millones o más de
esos 190 50 más o menos viven en brasil
entonces no hablan español hablemos de
que 140 y resto de millones hablan
español y no tienen actualmente en el
2019 ningún medio periodístico que les
cuente a ellos las noticias parece que
en nuestra región la exclusión en la
norma hasta cuando de información se
trata
ahora vivimos también en una época de
mucha conectividad hoy día son
muchísimos de esos 190 millones de niños
que tienen acceso a un smartphone oa una
tablet dona conecta una conexión a
internet que les da acceso a mucha
información los ponen en riesgo y rara
vez vemos a alguien haciendo una
mediación fiscalizadora para que los
niños entiendan cuáles de esos
contenidos que encuentran en la web son
buenos o son útiles digamos que hay una
gran tarea pendiente en cuanto a la
alfabetización de la información la
alfabetización periodística o la
alfabetización mediática veamos un
ejemplo concreto en costa rica pensemos
en una huelga que durante meses cierra
las escuelas
y los principales afectados que son los
niños no tienen ningún solo medio de
comunicación que les cuente a ellos la
historia que está ocurriendo el hecho
noticioso en su lenguaje con contexto
explicándoles cuáles son las causas y
cuáles son las consecuencias de algo que
ellos son los principales afectados de
algo que sufren de primera mano o
hablemos del caso de las vacunas del
papiloma que le están poniendo a niñas
costarricenses y los adultos discuten un
montón y los medios informan un montón
al respecto pero nadie le cuenta a las
niñas en su lenguaje un medio
periodístico una noticia hecha para
niños nadie la ha hecho nunca parece que
no importa hablamos del trabajo del
futuro y en la prensa todos los días
sale en los trabajos del futuro bueno no
tenemos nadie que le cuenta a los
trabajadores del futuro cuál va a ser su
realidad y hay una gran deuda la labor
del periodismo que es informar explicar
y contextualizar no se ha hecho nunca
para niños entonces veamos en ese
ambiente donde están todos
conectados y navegando con mucha
incertidumbre a veces o con buen
acompañamiento en otros casos que son
los mejores yo dije que hacemos hagamos
algo entonces se me ocurrió una idea
juntemos un grupo de expertos que pueda
asesorar un proyecto periodístico para
niños un proyecto que finalmente logre
informar con contexto y con realidad y
con mucha responsabilidad a todos los
niños de américa latina' juntemos gente
con perfiles interesantes como
neuropediatras psicopedagogos abogados
expertos en derechos de la infancia y
también expertos en comunicación
infantil para que asesoren a otro grupo
que va a ser de periodistas diseñadores
animadores digitales o educadores que
agarren las noticias que ya otros medios
serios producen y laskurain o las
adapten para que los niños las entiendan
o también que las produzcan imaginemos
un grupo tan pro como éste que pueda
agarrar las noticias que ya hacen el
semanario universidad delfín o la nación
el país la bbc o la deutsche welle y las
adapten para que los niños las entiendan
esos saldaría la deuda histórica del
periodismo y los medios de comunicación
con la niñez a mí me parece una gran
cosa yo no sé a ustedes pero es
importante o no yo estoy convencido de
que sí lo es
por eso finalmente cuando muchas
organizaciones y universidades o algunos
medios de gran trayectoria han comenzado
a hablar sobre la importancia de la
alfabetización periodística o la
alfabetización mediática informacional
como una manera de facultar a los niños
para que entiendan cuál información les
conviene y cuál es útil que manejen para
que entiendan cuáles son sus derechos
para que se involucren más en los
asuntos de su comunidad porque los
entienden porque alguien se preocupó por
contarse los como ellos necesitan
entenderlos para que puedan finalmente
ser incluidos en el mundo de la
información y participar y ser
actores actores no pasivos que puedan
interactuar con la realidad que puedan
ir más allá de ser consumidores y poder
incluso producir contenido mediático de
manera responsable y no como muchas
personas adultas lo hacen de manera muy
responsable a mí me ilusiona muchísimo
pensar que pronto no es algo que
tengamos que imaginar lo que muy pronto
podamos ver una plataforma robusta
responsable que produzca contenido
informativo para niños de todo el
continente y que finalmente habiendo
saldado la deuda histórica de los medios
de comunicación y el periodismo
latinoamericano con la población
infantil podamos entonces decir que
ahora los niños son ciudadanos de pleno
derecho que habían garantizado su
derecho al del acceso a la información
porque finalmente les contamos las
noticias que jamás les han contado
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]